this is this is super exciting because
it's not the academic problem of NLP of
natural language processing
understanding dialogue this is like real
world their stakes are high in a sense
that customers get frustrated quickly
people get frustrated quickly so you
have to get it right if to get that
interaction right so it's I love it but
so from that perspective
what what are the challenges today what
what are the problems that really need
to be solved and yes here I think first
and foremost as I mentioned that get the
basics right are still true
basically even the one-shot requests
which we think of as transactional
requests needs to work magically no
question about that Li if it doesn't
turn your light on and off you'll be
super frustrated even if I can complete
the night out for you and not do that
that is unacceptable for as a customer
right so that you have to get the
foundational understanding going very
well
the second aspect when I said more
conversational is as you imagine is more
about reasoning it is really about
figuring out what the latent goal is of
the customer based on what I have the
information now and the history and
what's the next best thing to do so
that's a complete reasoning and
decision-making problem just like
yourself driving car in but the goal is
still more finite here it evolves your
environment is super hard and
self-driving and the cost of a mistake
is huge here but there are certain
similarities but if you think about how
many decisions Alexa is making or
evaluating at any given time it's a huge
hypothesis space and we're only talked
about so far about what I think of
reactive decision in terms of you asked
for something and Alexis reacting to it
if you bring the proactive part which is
Alexa having hunches so any given
instance then you're it's really a
decision at any given point based on the
information Alexa has to determine
what's the best thing it needs to do so
these are the ultimate AI problem or
decisions based on the information you
have
you